want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some
amazing motivation from michelle obama
enjoy
[Music]
one of the things that we try to think
about especially when we work with kids
is consistency you know because
a a kid will believe you know a day like
we had in vietnam you can wake up either
feeling changed or you can feel like did
that happen
and then if it if nothing good ever
comes after that
it reinforces the disappointment that
they feel
on an ongoing basis it's like yeah they
came they saw
the cameras were here the lights were on
but weeks went by
and you know i never heard from them
again um
and that's that we try to avoid when we
work with kids
so when i was first lady whenever we had
a powerful
interaction with a group of kids whether
it was islington
whether it was in vietnam whether it was
in cambodia
it couldn't just be that moment we had
to we made
sure that we followed up at least two or
three or four
there's only so much i can do with this
big platform
but you guys as leaders you know that
consistent return
to them will be the thing that they
remember
it's not the first visit it's the second
and the third
and the fifth visit so because that's
the kind of repetition
that you need with children with your
own children
you know as you're teaching them
anything it's they take it in the more
you repeating
repeat it parenting is about repetition
nope
can't do it still can't
nope the answer is still no and probably
around the 10th
maybe the 100th time they'll be like i
guess it's no it works
but the same thing is true with the
positive reinforcement that you have in
the life of a child and
quite frankly that's true for any issue
that you're taking on
it's that once you take it on then do it
show up for the communities that you're
serving um
because so many of the communities that
we all work in have been disappointed
and they're used to that let down
they're used to that
sort of one one one hit and then we're
on
michelle obama's book becoming i know
everybody in here has it
[Applause]
it it it wasn't just the best-selling
memoir
book of the year it's the best-selling
memoir of old times
and what that says to me i think it's
like now 11.7 million probably 12 since
we've been sitting here
uh million what it says to me is that
it's such an extraordinary
time to be a strong confident
assured and above all else well
woman in the world today absolutely i
mean
so many people saw themselves in my
story
um it's also a time for owning our
stories
and i think that's part of what
resonated with people i mean a lot of
people came up and said well you were so
vulnerable
you was it hard for you to tell your
story to tell your truth
there were things you covered that were
difficult like trouble in your marriage
and trouble
having getting pregnant was that hard to
do and my response is no that's my story
i embrace every aspect of who i am
because as i've said i like my story i
like all the highs and lows and the
bumps in between
yeah yeah and i think that
you know what we learn from that is
people are
they are they gravitate to other
people's vulnerabilities
we gravitate to one another when we see
the best and the worst in ourselves
because it makes us feel human
we were talking with some of those young
women about confidence
yeah and you i think you said something
like don't let the haters
get to you the doubters yeah we live in
a world where there's people that want
to hate
you know whether they do it online from
their basement or wherever it is do you
ever can does that stuff ever get to you
you know you you practice not letting it
get to you you have to
develop protective tools for yourself
i tell young people first of all don't
read it you know don't
don't go into that sphere and take in
that energy
because that energy isn't even the full
reflection
of who we are as a people you know one
of the things i say that it's um
it's harder to hate up close you know
social media creates a distance
that allows people to say things that
they probably don't even mean
um so why take that in why why breathe
that air why drink that juice
when there's so many other things that
you can focus on
so over the span of my lifetime it
wasn't just the eight years in the white
house but
over the span of a full career and being
a mother
and all the worries that come with that
and you know
having a solid marriage you have to
learn how to protect yourself
emotionally
and how to do the things that keep you
feeling whole
and so i i apply those whenever i can
what are those things that keep you
feeling home surrounding myself
by positive energy because for every
hater out there there are
10 other people who were there ready to
give you an attaboy
so why don't we listen to the
those few naysayers and not let the real
true
positive energy in so i learned to do
that i surrounded myself with people
who support me who remind me of my
strengths who build up my confidence
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special
free training to help you get it where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you
a link to an unlisted video to your
email
to every day shift your confidence and
self-belief forward
the science says it can take up to 254
days
of consecutive action to make a habit
stick
and i want you to get the habit of
self-confidence and self-belief the link
to join absolutely for free is in the
description below
i want you all to stay true to the most
real most sincere
most authentic parts of yourselves
doubts don't go away
you just learn how to deal with them
first of all
you got to be uh open to taking some
risks
and not being afraid to fail before we
move to the next slide i did want to ask
you about
uh one aspect of your family that truly
is an example of how
character building and cohesiveness and
planning and discipline
are part of many many african-american
families and that has to do with how you
would end up going
every place early i loved the story of
that and how and why you did that
well again it gets back to my dad right
because he was
infirmed he wanted to make sure that he
was
never the reason why we would be late
for anything
and he would always be the first one
ready
and me who absolutely adored my dad
i would be the second person ready
and it got to a point where if we had to
be somewhere at five
and it took us a half an hour to get
there he would be ready
at four so we could be ready to go at 4
30. but then he would start to say
once he got ready at four are you guys
ready to my mom and my sister they'd be
like no you said we're leaving at 4
30. and he would continually back the
time up but that's that's just an aside
but
um we spent a lot of time getting places
early and just like this morning
we stayed together at the hotel and they
told me to be ready at 9
25. i was there at 9 10 9 15.
and that's on time for us so she wasn't
ready
i didn't have to be ready until 9 45.
see these are the conversations that we
have
that are a result of having
a father you know where time was
important see
i don't do anything late i think eight
years in the white house my staff will
tell you
with tina's chin is over there laughing
it's like
we do not do late and i have a husband
who
learned better
about that you know
he was that those he's a hawaii time
it's like
dude dude you are just starting to get
ready and we're leaving at 4 30.
it's like so you know that all comes
from my father
because being on time was a reflection
of control for him
you know when when you're walking with a
disability you know this was before the
ada
you know this was before there were
access ramps and things like that you
imagine my father thinking when he's
going to one of craig's games
where am i going to park how far do i
have to walk you know when do where am i
going to sit
well well i have to climb up the
bleachers but if i get there early
because he was going to be at
every game he was the dad at everything
he was driving other kids from the west
side to league games because
all the kids who didn't have parents
could count on my dad
to be at every practice that he could if
he wasn't on a shift
so he knew every gym he knew every
parking space
um we didn't see it as that i think when
we were younger it was just dead
come on chill out you know but now in
hindsight we realized that his
disability
because he didn't want to be the excuse
for us to miss out or to not have
something because of something he
couldn't do
so he he accommodated for us and taught
us the importance of respect for other
people's time
respect for other people's abilities it
doesn't matter that your first lady of
the united states
if you've got a room full of people
waiting for you and you told them you
were going to start at seven
well doggone it their time means
something who knows what it took for
them to get
to that space to get in those chairs
what has been
the best advice you received from your
teacher or professor
oh i've gotten a lot of great advice
from teachers mentors professors
throughout the year so
first of all you got to be open to
taking some risks
and not being afraid to fail failure is
the key to success
so when you get to college you got to
raise your hand you have to be engaged
don't be the kid thinking oh i shouldn't
be here and maybe i'm not smart enough
and maybe
you know no you are more than capable
of going to college being successful and
going on doing whatever you want in life
i sit here because i am you all there is
no difference between
me and you working class kid growing up
on the south side of chicago
growing up with doubts and fears just
like all of you all do i know exactly
how you all are feeling and kids out
there who are thinking maybe i'm not
ready maybe i'm not good enough maybe i
can't afford it
but what teachers and mentors have told
me is that yes you can and you must
so get in there and be bold with your
intelligence raise your hand get support
when you need it
uh and know that we all got here because
somebody helped us
i want you all to stay true to the most
real most sincere
most authentic parts of yourselves i
want you to ask
those basic questions who do you want to
be
what inspires you how do you want to
give back
and then i want you to take a deep
breath
and trust yourselves to chart your own
course
and make your mark on the world maybe it
feels like you're supposed to go to law
school
but what you really want to do is teach
little kids
maybe your parents are expecting you to
come back home after you graduate but
you're feeling a pull to travel the
world
i want you to listen to those thoughts
i want you to act with both your mind
but also your heart
and no matter what path you choose
i want you to make sure it's you
choosing it
and not someone else we learned about
dignity
and decency that how hard you work
matters more than how much you make
that helping others means more than just
getting ahead yourself
we learned about honesty and integrity
that the truth matters that that you
don't take
shortcuts or play by your own set of
rules
and success doesn't count unless you
earn it fair and square
speaking of the current climate you know
one of the things that you have now
become
famous forever for is that when they go
low
we go high and that ain't always
easy that's not always easy and what i
wanted to ask you that
in this climate where low has taken new
lows
how do you maintain a high and not
appear to be
passive and not lose your equilibrium
because
low has gone lower yeah yes
well because going low is easy which is
why people
go to it it's easy to go low it's easy
to lead by fear it's easy to be divisive
it's easy
to make people feel afraid that's the
easy thing and it's also the short-term
thing and for me you know what i learned
from my husband what i learned in eight
years at the white house is that
this this life this world our
responsibility in it is so much
bigger than us right so what i have to
keep in mind is usually when i want to
go low
it's all about my own ego you know it's
not about solving anything it's not
about fixing anything
it's about seeking revenge on the thing
that happened to you
yeah and when you as oprah you talk
about purpose
yes what it's all about and my purpose
on this planet is not to
just take care of my own little ego you
know there is a bigger
purpose for me out there so when i
respond to something i have to think
about that light
i'm trying to shine what role model am i
trying to be what what are the words
that i'm going to say and how will it
affect young people who are looking at
me
that's the bigger picture that puts you
in a position to think high
because if you're thinking about the
long term you don't take the short term
measure of getting even with somebody
right here and now today because it
makes you feel good in the moment
if it's not going to fix a problem if
it's not going to move the needle
then you're not going high you're just
being selfish
what's the best advice do you think
you've given your daughters oh
gosh i give them so much advice they're
so sick of me
you know now that they're in college i
have these texting did i ever did i tell
you
to remember little things like you are
eating some green things aren't you um
but what is the thing that over the
years was a running theme in your house
that you said
over and over you know what i tell them
is what i continue to tell themselves is
that
they have to walk their own walk you
know they they cannot define themselves
by looking at each other or looking at
me or their dad they have to take the
time to get to know
themselves give themselves a moment to
figure out who they want to be in the
world
not who they think i want them to be not
what the rest of the world
says about them but to really think
about
how they want to shape their lives and
how they want to
move in this world so i don't want them
measuring themselves by external
influences and for young girls that is
hard to do
oh you know that is a very hard thing to
do and everybody should understand that
as a responsibility it's instagram
culture oh it it drives me crazy it was
hard
when it was hard with just cable tv when
you're watching all the images and
in music videos it's i don't know
exponentially difficult
with with social media when you're
comparing yourself to everybody on
social media
so i constantly have to remind them
that they have to live in their own skin
and that takes time too
and i try to make sure they understand
that that that unfolding of
understanding who you
are it it is a journey of becoming you
don't know it all
in your 20s when you ask the question is
it necessary to have
a a hero a role model and yeah i think
yes
absolutely the thing we get wrong is who
that role model should be
you know we always think we when we say
role model well it's got to be somebody
famous it's got to be julia roberts or
michelle obama
you know but the truth is as julia
pointed out that
the heroes the role models that have the
greatest impact are the
people that are surrounding children
right there you know it's it's not the
big it's not the president of the united
states
it's your mom it's your neighbor it's
that teacher
um and so in that with with that view of
what mo
role models are i think all people do
have them
if they value who they have in their
lives you know
everybody has somebody
that that they can look to but if we
devalue
some of that positive input because we
don't think that
they're important then we miss out on
who our role model is
you know we're missing the person in our
lives that is giving us that
encouragement
so at six a.m every morning i had to get
on a city bus
and ride for an hour sometimes more just
to get to school
and i was willing to do that because i
was willing to do whatever it took for
me to go to college
i set my sights high i decided i was
going to princeton
but i quickly realized that for me a kid
like me
getting into princeton wasn't just going
to happen on its own
see i went to a great school but at my
school we had so many kids so few
guidance counselors they were dealing
with hundreds of students
so they didn't always have much time to
help me personally
get my applications together plus
i knew i couldn't afford to go on a
bunch of college visits
i couldn't hire a personal tutor i
couldn't enroll in s.a.t
prep classes we didn't have the money
and then
get this some of my teachers
straight up told me that i was setting
my sights too high
they told me i was never going to get
into a school like princeton
and i still hear that doubt ringing in
my head
so it was clear to me that nobody
was going to take my hand and lead me
to where i needed to go instead it was
going to be
up to me to reach my goal i would have
to chart my own course
see i learned respect
from how my parents cared for my great
aunt and uncle
how my mother would wake up in the
middle of the night to check on my great
aunt
how my father would prop himself up
against the bathroom seek each morning
leaning hard on his crutches to give my
great uncle a shave
i learned integrity from my parents
that living a good life is not about
being wealthy or
powerful it's about being honest
and doing what you say you're gonna do
it's about how you
act when no one is watching
and whether you're the same person on
the outside as you are on the inside
and when i arrived at princeton the
whole college experience
was a mystery to me i was sleeping in a
room with strangers
and as i looked around at all the other
students
who had come from wealthy families and
were third and fourth generation
princetonians i didn't always feel like
i fit in
i was a little lonely at times and
so what i understood was that i needed
to build a community of my own
right so i worked hard to make new
friends in my classes and at the campus
cultural center
i reached out to professors and
administrators around campus
and soon enough i had built a wonderful
group of friends and supporters that
became my family
away from home and i relied on that
family
probably as heavily as you rely on your
family
stopping by folks rooms when i was bored
calling up folks when i needed to vent
leaning on them when i was
anxious or down or just plain tired
and what i know now is that i would not
have made it through
that college period without that group
of people by my
side my parents worked hard to pay the
bills
and to keep a roof over our heads but
even though my parents couldn't give
us material things they gave us
something
much more precious they gave
me and my brother strong values
they taught us to treat others with
dignity and respect
they taught us to push for excellence in
every single thing we did
they taught us to be humble and to be
grateful for
everything we had they taught us to put
every last bit of effort into our
education
and to take pride in our work
they taught us that our circumstances
didn't define us and that if we believed
in ourselves
if we made the most of every single
opportunity
we could build our own destinies and
accomplish
anything we put our minds to and i'll be
honest
i didn't find my passion until long
after college
heck until after law school i mean the
truth is i spent
still spent way too much of my time at
princeton
continuing to chase grades and check
boxes and climb higher and higher i went
on to law school i did the same thing
by the time i was in my mid-20s i had
everything i was told
i should want fancy job at a prestigious
law firm
a big office a nice paycheck
but on the inside something was missing
and so after a few
knocks i finally asked myself some big
questions
simple questions what did i want out of
my life
what makes me happy what do i care about
yeah simple questions that i never
bothered to ask
too busy checking boxes and soon i
realized that what
i really wanted was pretty simple
i wanted to give back to the people
around me to the world around me
i wanted to live my life by the
principle
that to whom much is given much is
expected
so
for me that led me to quit
that fancy job and since then i've
dedicated my life to giving back
i've worked to train young people for
careers in public service i've started
community outreach programs at a college
in a hospital
and today is first lady i'm working to
honor our nation's military families and
help our children
grow up healthy but as i look back
i wish i'd asked myself what i really
wanted
when i was sitting right where you are
so graduates my message to all of you
today is this
do not waste a minute living someone
else's dream
each of us has unique gifts
but it takes a lot of work
a lot of real work to discover what
brings you joy
it just doesn't happen it requires you
spending
some time and you won't find what you
love
simply by checking boxes or padding your
gpa you won't figure it out
only by listening to your guidance
counselor your friends or even your
parents
you can only find your passion by
looking inside yourself
if i was going to protect them i had to
number one protect myself
and protect my time so
i knew going into this role that i
didn't want to waste any time that any
time i spin away from my kids and i
i actually took this on even before i
became
first lady even as a lawyer as a vice
president at a hospital
one of the things i realized is that if
you do not take control over your time
in your life
other people will gobble it up if you
don't prioritize yourself
you constantly start falling lower and
lower on your list your kids fall lower
and lower on your list
so by the time you got here you knew how
to do that i knew how to do that
read write read read if the president
were here
one of his greatest strengths is
reading that's one of the reasons why
he's a good communicator why he's such a
good writer he's a voracious reader
so we're trying to get our girls no
matter what to just be
to love reading and to challenge
themselves with what they read and not
just read the gossip books
but to
push themselves beyond and do things
that maybe they wouldn't do
so i would encourage you all to to read
read read just keep reading and writing
is another skill it's practice it's
practice
the more you write the better you get
drafts
our kids are learning the first draft
means nothing
you're going to do seven ten drafts
that's writing it's not failure
it's not not the teacher not liking you
because it's all marked up and read
when you get to be a good writer you
mark your own stuff in red
and you rewrite and you rewrite and you
rewrite that's what writing is
and if you come out with those skills
and then you're confident and you can
articulate and you can stand up straight
and look
anybody in the eye and say this is who i
am
it's a pleasure to meet you that's one
of the things we try to do with our
mentoring program with young girls
my message to them is if you can walk
into the white house
and meet the first lady and say my name
is
how are you and look me in the eye then
there's nothing you can't do
that's why it's important if you guys
walked here
are sitting here in front of all these
people
standing tall asking questions using
your voice
you have to practice that these arenas
just show up again and again
and then you just get used to it the
nerves go away
and you start relaxing into your own
abilities
but it's practice be supportive of each
other
i mean i i just can't say this enough we
have to be our best friends each other
that means we cannot be catty we cannot
compete
and see one person's failure is our
success
we can all rise together okay we can all
win and and we're sometimes
taught in our societies that we have to
compete and we have to hold each other
back in order for one of us to succeed
that is not true we need each other
i've always felt a deep sense of
obligation to make the biggest
impact possible with this incredible
platform
so i took on issues that were personal
to me
issues like helping families raise
healthier kids
honoring the incredible military
families that i'd met out on the
campaign trail
inspiring our young people to value
their education and
finish college now
some folks criticize my choices for not
being bold enough
but these were my choices my issues
and i decided to tackle them in a way
that felt most authentic to me
in a way that was both substantive and
strategic
but also fun and hopefully inspiring so
i immerse myself in the policy details
i worked with congress on legislation i
gave speeches to ceos
military generals hollywood executives
but i also worked to ensure that my
efforts would resonate with kids and
families
and that meant doing things in a
creative and unconventional way
so yeah i planted a garden and hula
hooped on the white house lawn with kids
i did some mom dancing on tv
i celebrated military kids with kermit
the frog
i asked folks across the country to wear
their alma mater's t-shirts for college
signing day
and at the end of the day by staying
true to the me i've always known i found
that this journey has been incredibly
freeing because no matter what happened
i had the peace of mind of knowing that
all of the chatter
the name calling the doubting all of it
was just
noise it did not define me
it didn't change who i was and most
importantly it couldn't hold me back
i have learned that as long as i hold
fast to my beliefs and values and follow
my own moral compass
then the only expectations i need to
live up to
are my own you see barack and i were
both raised by families who didn't have
much in the way money or material
possessions but
who had given us something far more
valuable
their unconditional love their
unflinching
sacrifice and the chance to go places
they had never imagined for themselves
my father was a pump operator at the
city water plant
and he was diagnosed with multiple
sclerosis when my brother and i were
young
and even as a kid i i knew there were
plenty of days when he was in pain
and i knew there were plenty of mornings
when it was a struggle for him to simply
get out of bed
but every morning i watched my father
wake up with a smile
grab his walker prop himself up against
the bathroom sink and slowly shave
and button his uniform and when he
returned home after a long day's work my
brother and i would
would stand at the top of the stairs of
our little apartment
patiently waiting to greet him watching
as he reached down to lift one leg
and then the other to slowly climb his
way into our arms
but despite these challenges my dad
hardly ever missed a day of work
he and my mom were determined to give me
and my brother the kind of education
they could only dream of you're getting
advice
uh from around the world it seems a
former british prime minister tony
blair's wife sheree blair
did you happen to hear or read what she
said no well she warns that you will
have to learn
to take a back seat and that you will
not be able to have
any kind of a career and she says that
that will be a very difficult thing to
do
yeah i think it just depends on the
person i have never been
the kind of person who's defined myself
by a career or a job
i just never have people used to ask me
that during the course of the campaign
is it hard for you to have stepped off
the track and
devoted your your life to his dream
but the truth is is that i believe in
this man as our president
and his vision for the countries and if
that meant you know stepping away from
my particular job for a year and a half
or
four or for eight years if you do what
you're supposed to do right
then uh you know that's a small
sacrifice
uh to make and it's enough to keep you
fulfilled
oh well i've got these great kids too i
mean and the truth is
you know and barack knows this about me
i i love kids and i love my kids and
this isn't to say that
anyone who's working doesn't but i
enjoy the balance of
having a job and having a set of
projects and
being able to have time to make sure
that i'm in the girls lives
and making sure that we have time as a
family i mean that's a full plate
i don't view myself as being in a
position where i'm twiddling my thumbs
and
and wondering how am i going to get
through the day
i've never experienced that in my life
he reminds me that we
are playing a long game here and that
change
is hard and change is slow and it never
happens all at once but
eventually we get there we always do
we we get there because of folks like my
dad
folks like barack's grandmother men and
women who who said to themselves
i may not have a chance to fulfill my
dreams but maybe
my children will maybe my grandchildren
will
see so many of us stand here tonight
because of their sacrifice
and longing and steadfast love because
time and again
they swallowed their fears and doubts
and did what was hard
think about one of my heroines marian
wright edelman
class of 1960 working
as a young civil rights lawyer down in
mississippi
attorneys in judges chambers refused to
shake her hand
the sheriff locked the doors against her
when she came to visit her clients in
jail
she was always careful to leave the door
open when she started her car in the
morning
that way if somebody planted a car bomb
she had
a chance of being injured rather than
killed
but through it all she continued to
represent her clients
she continued to resist unjust laws with
every
fiber of her being
then there's janet bragg class of 1925
who was determined to be a pilot
when she was barred from flying out of
segregated airports
she worked with her flying school
classmates and instructors to build
their own airfield
when she was rejected from the women air
force service pilots because
of a race she enrolled in a civilian
training program instead when she
completed
her training but an instructor unfairly
prevented her from
receiving her license she picked up and
moved to chicago
passed the exam and became the first
african-american woman
to earn a commercial pilot's license
of her experiences she said
there was so many things they said women
couldn't do and blacks couldn't do
every defeat to me was a challenge
for six generations that is
what spelman women have done they have
seen every defeat
as a challenge now did they have moments
of doubt
anxiety and fear did they have moments
of despair
when they thought about giving up or
giving in
of course they did we all do
and i am no exception there were times
when i felt lonely and overwhelmed
during my freshman year
and what i want you to remember is if
that happens to you
i want you to keep pushing forward just
keep pushing forward and i want you to
reach out and ask for help
i know your teachers tell you that all
the time
but please understand that no one gets
through college or
life for that matter alone no one
i certainly didn't so the minute
you feel like you're struggling the
minute
i want you to ask for help don't wait
seek out a professor you trust go to the
writing center or the
the counseling center talk to older
students who know the ropes
and can give you some advice and if the
first person you ask isn't friendly or
helpful then ask
a second person and then a third and a
fourth
my point is keep asking until you get
the answers you need
to get you back on track when i uh
i got to college that that happened to
me during my very first semester
i took a class on greek mythology yes
greek mythology that was way over my
head
i found myself sitting in a lecture hall
full of juniors and seniors
how did i get there struggling just to
keep up and by the time i took the
midterm exam all i could muster
was a c and it was the very first c i'd
ever gotten and i was devastated
but instead of wilting i found a way to
fight through it i poured my heart and
soul into a paper i spent a lot of time
talking to the professors before and
after class
and in the end i ended up getting a good
grade in that class but what i learned
was
far more important than that letter
grade from that experience what i
learned
was that when something doesn't go your
way
you just gotta adjust you've got to
dig deep and work like crazy and that's
when you'll find
out what you're really made of during
those hard times
but you can only do that if you're
willing to put yourself in a position
where you might fail and that's why so
often failure is the key to success for
so many great
people take steve jobs who was fired
from apple
early in his career and now his ipods
and ipads and iphones have
revolutionized the entire world
oprah was demoted from her first job as
a news anchor
now she doesn't even need a last name
and then there's this guy barack obama
who lost
i could take up a whole afternoon
talking about his failures
but he lost his first race for congress
and now he gets to call himself my
husband
be laughed at get it wrong trip fall
and then get back up do your homework
do chores have responsibilities because
what i tell my kids you have to practice
who you want to be you know you don't
wake up one morning
and you're suddenly who you think you
want to be you have to
put some energy into it so if you want
to be an honest person
you have to be an honest person every
day even starting at three
and four and five right if you're going
to be a hard worker hard work doesn't
just
appear you have to practice hard work
you have to
practice effort um you know and and i
also encourage them uh and
try to help them understand that good
things don't come easy
you know with that effort you know
that's where you grow
that's where growth is some of the best
times in my life when i've grown it's
when i've done something hard
when i've overcome a fear you don't
realize that when you're doing it but
when you come out
on the other side you realize wow i've
really
stepped up so i push my girls this is
what i tell my daughters every day
do not be afraid to fail
because that oftentimes is the thing
that keeps us as women
and girls back because we think we have
to be right
we think we have to be perfect we think
that we can't stumble
and the only way you succeed in life the
only way you learn
is by failing it's not the failure it's
what you do
after you fail you know do you let it
eat you up
do you quit do you give up or do you let
it
bolster you does it serve as as
the challenge in your mind to do more to
take some risks
to step outside of your comfort zone are
you going to throw up your hands and say
that progress will never come are you
going to get angry and lash out
are you going to turn inward and just
give in to despair and frustration
or are you going to take a deep breath
straighten your shoulders lift up your
head and do what barack obama has always
done as he says when they go low
i go high that's the choice
barack and i have made that's what has
kept us sane
over the years we simply do not allow
space in our hearts minds or souls
for darkness instead
we choose faith faith in ourselves in
the power of hard work
faith in our god whose overwhelming love
sustains us
every single day that's what we choose
we choose love our love
for our children our commitment to
leaving them a better world our love for
our country which has given us so many
blessings and advantages
our love for our fellow citizens parents
working hard to support their kids men
and women in uniform who
risk everything to keep us safe
young people from the toughest
backgrounds who never
stop believing in their dreams young
people like so many of you
that's what we choose
and we choose excellence
we choose to tune out all the noise and
strive for
excellence in everything we do
no cutting corners no taking shortcuts
no whining
we give 120 every single time because
excellence excellence is the most
powerful answer you can give to the
doubters and the haters
[Applause]
it's also the most powerful thing you
can do for yourself
because the process of striving and
struggling and pushing yourself to new
heights
see that's how you develop your
god-given talents
that's how you make yourself stronger
and smarter and more
able to make a difference for others we
as women
we as minorities sort of take for
uh we underestimate in ourselves and
that is i
i'm pretty smart yeah i work pretty hard
um i'm i'm good at what i do i i have
really good instincts i have great ideas
and i can execute and i say that out
loud
because we as women don't like
pat ourselves on the back for we're
always sort of
deferring yes you know we we we seed our
power
so easily and i want young girls out
there to know look
live out loud live out loud and
understand that what's in your
brain is is really useful
do not hide it don't don't dumb it down
don't apologize for it just
put it on the table and let people deal
with it
because we silence ourselves when we
drop
our guards and we let ourselves become
vulnerable and that vulnerability allows
us to
share our true stories with each other
not
you know not the the stuff on the
surface but
the things that really connect us like
how we were
raised the values that we learned around
the dinner table
the people who impacted us in our lives
the things that made us scared
that you know the things that gave us
courage
that when we share that truth
um we can see ourselves in each other a
little bit better
no matter no matter what um
you know your dad is someone that i've
you take the politics out of it and i
had an opportunity to sit
by your father at funerals
the highs and the lows and we
shared stories about our kids and about
our parents
our values are the same we disagree on
policy but we don't disagree on humanity
we don't disagree about love and
compassion
i think that's true for all of us it's
just that
we get lost in in our fear
of what's different so yeah we've gotta
you know we gotta work on that but i
think that this generation coming up
you know i think they know more than we
did each generation knows a little bit
more
you know while one can argue that social
media is problematic
it's also opening young people up to
new ideas to each other to other parts
of the world
my hope is that they will be more
open-minded and more secure in who they
are
so that they can welcome other people's
stories into the mix but
it has to begin with us being willing to
be vulnerable and share who we really
are
with our neighbors so that we're not
strangers to each other
and that way we don't we can't let
somebody else from the outside
tear us apart because we know each other
right i know
you i've seen you we broke bread
together
you know i may not agree with you but i
like you you are my neighbor
that takes work and commitment now i've
got a very special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through but when you get
motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you when
barack came in office one of the very
first things he did
was to set what he calls a north star
goal for the entire country that by the
year 2020
uh the year that all of you will be
graduating from college
that this country will have the highest
proportion
of college graduates in the world
now barack set this goal because as a
generation ago
we were number one in college graduates
but over the past couple of decades this
country has slipped
all the way to 12th we've slipped and
that's unacceptable and we've got a lot
of work to do
to turn that around and get back on top
but barack didn't just set that goal
because it's good for our country
he did it because he knows how important
higher education is
to all of you as individuals because
when the year 2020 rolls around
nearly two-thirds of all jobs in this
country
are going to require some form of
training
beyond high school and that means
whether it's
a vocational program community college a
four-year university
you all are going to need some form of
higher education
in order to build the kind of lives that
you want for yourselves
good careers to be able to provide for
your families
if you want some amazing motivation from
lisa nichols check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there people often want
to call me the
exception like oh my god you're the
exception no i'm not the exception i'm
an average ordinary woman
who chose every day to make one more
extraordinary decision